- On the flip side of how
you make a union work,
I can't think of any one,
and Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
who I've just spent the last
week voraciously studying,
and if you're watching her documentary,
Gloria Steinem comes up,
and Gloria Steinem is one
of the great world changers,
game changers, and when she
came up into your world,
how fast was it before you
said yes to portraying her?
- Oh man, it was immediate.
Julie Taymor contacted me
about it and I was like,
"Yes, absolutely. I would
love to be a part of this."
I don't think it was after,
it wasn't until after that,
that I really thought
about what it would entail.
She's so iconic, and she's so
meaningful to so many people
and has been emblematic, I think,
of the women's movement
in the United States.
So I also didn't realize
how challenging it would be
because she is,
she's actually has a quiet
recessive quality sometimes.
She's known as one of the
world's great listeners.
So it's not a very active
thing to play as an actor,
and her speech pattern is,
her inner accent is very
unique and, but she's not,
she's someone who will step back
and promote other people and
their activism and their words.
And so it was very, very
challenging, but so fantastic.
Just trying to absorb
who she was in that way.
- I think for as much as
I care about everyone,
and I'm such a people person,
I'm not sure I'm
comfortable in the silences.
I definitely am a good listener,
but I'm a huge talker also.
And these women,
they just possess sort
of an inner confidence,
which is so admirable,
but what they do with it
is all this outward protection of others.
- Absolutely.
One of the things that
really struck me about Gloria
is that she's not
reactive. She's not rash.
People said really horrific things to her.
They just loaded it on her.
And she always came from
a point of, like I said,
she would listen, she'd wait.
And then she would respond,
but she never responded
with any kind of heat.
She always responded with intellect,
and she wasn't cruel to anyone ever
and incredibly tolerant
of other people's views.
So I do think about that.
I really think when I'm
talking to people, I'm like,
"What would Gloria do?
How would she react?"
Maybe take take the time
to be more like her.
- You're not going to
want to miss this movie.
Julie Taymor does direct
and she's such a visionary.
- Yeah, she really is.
- And this film is no exception.
I think the Glorias are dissected in ways
that are very unprecedented and unique.
And there's an incredible
big surprise ending
that you won't want to miss,
and really quickly, "Dear Evan Hansen."
(Julie laughing)
(screams)
I love his play so much.
- That's how I feel too.
- Oh my god, are you excited?
- I am so excited. I'm beside myself.
Honestly, I can't believe it.
It's really, yeah. I
can't believe it happened.
- This story I also feel is
just so important for people.
We talk about mental health.
We talk about all these issues now
that are trying to be
more in the forefront
and on the table.
And then Ben Platt, a role
he seemed born to play.
And for a lot of people watching the play
was the moment everything really clicks
as his relationship with his mother,
and you'll be playing her,
and I'm so excited for this
to have everyone have access to it.
- Oh, I feel so lucky
and it really is a
beautiful, beautiful piece.
And I think it will
make a wonderful movie.
- I think so too.
And I have just the biggest
pompoms rooting you on always.
And thank you so much
for gracing our show with your presence.
"The Glorias" will be available
streaming on Amazon Prime.
(upbeat music)